seven days only even late to dinner
every single day four stops bug the crap
up three countries no kids
hi I'm Hannah and I'm the world's okay
it's mom now I'm laying here on the
couch and it's very quiet and why is
that because the kids aren't in this
episode as most of you know I just
turned 30 and for my birthday I wanted
to do something a little bit different
so I decided to surprise my mom the
person who gave me life
with a seven-day trip through Europe
just the two of us for my 30th birthday
we made a lot of memories we had a lot
of fun and here's what happened day 1 of
this trip was flying it is no joke
getting to Europe it is a very long
flight so we just got on the taxi in
Amsterdam and we're a little ragged he
didn't sleep much this is our room rooms
on boats are not like hotel rooms but
this one's actually really nicely sized
our room has a little balcony we're on
about because we wanted to hit a lot of
countries in one trip and the solution
is a river cruise it's called you by
Uniworld full-disclosure Uniworld
provided this cruise for free so we're
super close to land
you don't really sale much but you see
beautiful scenery when you do sail it's
perfect for you yes I love it but our
boat is not black
so edgy yeah so it's easy to find look
at this the other great thing about this
trip for me was all the meals are
provided on the boat and what they do is
that each stop in each city they go
shopping for ingredients so you're
getting a really good taste of the
cuisine of wherever you are you just
don't have to figure it out for yourself
but honestly I'm most excited in
Amsterdam to eat a bunch of cheese
because I didn't realized there were so
many cheese shops here they look
incredible today was just a really
really delicious dinner and a really fun
sneak peak of Amsterdam and tomorrow is
gonna be so much fun so it will be
rested hopefully till tomorrow on day 2
we were still in Amsterdam good morning
one thing I forgot about my mom she's
always late me let's go she's fully
clothed stop it
we started the day with an amazing boat
ride through the canals Amsterdam is
built with all of these canals running
through the entire city and it was just
a beautiful way to see a lot of
Amsterdam quickly without having to walk
and then that was followed by a food
tour stroopwafels and it's warm they
have some really iconic foods like this
fried cod that's mind-blowing ly
delicious stop number 3 cheese I did not
realize how amazing Dutch cheese is and
how abundant it is there it was long
we're still going it's so pretty though
we're back in the room oh my gosh we had
such a packed day ok but tell me what
you're gonna do you're just recording ok
but tell me what you're going to talk
about what we did today I want our
favorite part what are you right now yes
I'm gonna hurting right now yes you have
to tell me we love cheese and the cheese
here is unbelievable it's blue cheese
and it's lavender and it colored with
flower petals and laughs
but it's not blue cheese as in blue
cheese it's lavender cheese this cheese
right here chili pesto caca be cheese I
could cut some cheese for you right now
that's the joke at the end of day two
the boat took off to our next
destination
my mom just posted up at the window of
our room taking pictures and just being
like hey look oh yeah
cows so she has about 45 pictures of
cows at night and energy-generating
windmills not the cute Dutch windmills
the ugly ones I'm in bed trying to sleep
so I'm like mom put the phone down and
just try to go to sleep it's better get
better this better not be for the whole
trip on day three we were still in the
Netherlands we just mosey it on down to
a different city we're in Harlem a city
I'd never heard of in the Netherlands
but it's absolutely amazing and it was
my mom's favorite part of the trip
Kimmy I'm trying to walk can't do two
things at oh my gosh it's my fault
it's her fault she woke me up being with
my mom in such close quarters were in a
cruise-ship room so it is bringing back
memories of when I was a teenager we're
walking back to the boat but it's a
really far walk and then we're taking
off right away and headed to Germany
we are back out on the water I just love
when I'm in a new place tasting a bunch
of new stuff because a lot of it is
flavors that I've never had before this
is our boat at night
look at that little heart day four in
Cologne we actually felt confident
enough to walk on our own to the
Cathedral if we're in a new city I will
find the cemetery we found a cemetery
look at this
I live for creepy stuff like that we're
headed back to the boat she wore no hat
today in the Sun so I'm not happy with
that
you didn't mean it we're inside you're
not we're walking
I have no we're back to the boat all she
does tell me to prune sunscreen and put
on a hat and put on makeup that's all I
hear do you want lipstick oh did you put
sunscreen did you get a hat I'm 30 years
old I'm still your mom I don't need no
dang hat we're just supposed to go to
dinner my mom's getting dressed so it'll
be about 2 2 hours I think by the time
we get there ha ha hey just whatever I
too know that my mom's insulting my hair
it's not my favorite oh my gosh
that's inside
you get out of the way this is our
relationship felt like my mom and I
roast each other a lot this is beautiful
oh never mind like we do not let
anything slip by so I might sound mean
oh it's just how we are
it's 2:00 in the morning we're so
jet-lagged and we nap today on a such
bad choice we're wearing our PJs that my
mom brought our matching PJ's see look
look at these matching PJ's no well I'm
not showing your face tomorrow's a big
big big day I'm so excited
good eye everybody day five stop was a
city called Judas Haim in Germany it's
this beautiful area just filled with
castles posh and there's a castle up
there this is like fairytale land is
here currently I am to a castle oh my
goodness this is it's legit oh my
goodness this was my favorite part of
the entire trip I think it's just
because it's something so foreign to me
the second we stepped foot in this
castle I wanted to cry the whole time it
was so beautiful
I don't know why I got so choked out Oh
Castle Wow that is like the coolest
things I've ever done in my life
same stasek was in Frankfurt did a lot
of shopping you do a lot of exploring we
have wine and paints
at the boat it was a cute little
surprised actually that a boat offered a
pink class on the top deck it was really
good so as our last full day came to an
end my mom and I just kind of recap'd on
what we had done we're really nervous
for customs no we're not I'm afraid
they're gonna take our cheese you just
want to keep let's just say that we've
eaten a lot because it's it this cruise
is 21 and older so you don't get the
kids and stuff but um so it's fun yeah
we should get to sleep we have to get up
very early I hope we actually wake up
what we have to we don't have a choice I
know I hope we don't miss our train well
we can't miss our train oh you might no
we can't no well you haven't packed your
suitcases I know what I'm doing the day
7 was a travel day we weren't quite
ready to leave Europe so we hopped on
the train to Paris spent literally less
than 24 hours there we shopped we ate
and saw the Eiffel Tower we ate some
more pastries we went to a museum we saw
some art and we went to the airport and
went back home and that is how you do
Paris and 24 hours by the time we landed
at home I was just ready to hibernate
but it was so amazing to see the kids
and Matt and bring them their gifts and
their treats now traveling with my mom
was the best she's so fun to travel with
we get along really well she is my mom
so there's definitely like you know mom
daughter relationship stuff as I
ventured into motherhood my mom and I
became more like peers because I
understand what she's going through and
vice versa it's surprising because I
remember when I was a teenager and it
was like
like I never thought we'd get to a point
where I'd want to like spend a week with
her and now that I'm turning 30 like
that's the only thing I want in my life
is just a week with my mom I don't know
what I'd do without her I love you mom
so that's all I got for today I'm Hannah
and if you've taken a memorable trip
write it in the comments tell me where
you went cuz maybe I'll go there next or
if you have an idea for a future video
or a future trip for us to take leave
that in the comments as well now if
you'll please excuse me I still have not
unpacked and I probably got to do that
until next time
[Music]
heizaburo fight